AUBREY PLAZA:
Isn't it just crazy
that you're in the cast,
and you're in this hit show.
I guess. Is it crazy for you?
I'm not even here.
You have to answer
some questions.
I'm the interviewer.
That's not--
That's not correct.
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Episode two, Harper and Ethan
have dinner with Cameron
and Daphne.
And they get into a conversation
about having kids.
And I think it kind of
catches them off guard
a little bit.
Do you want to have kids?
Uh...
-Yeah.
They kind of touch a nerve
without realizing,
by asking us about, like,
our sex life.
And where we're saying,
"I know we're fine."
We do it, you know,
enough, like...
We think we're good,
and then by the end of dinner,
I'm like, "Oh.
Maybe we're not."
The problem is, I'm more of
a morning sex guy,
and Harper is not
a morning person.
DAPHNE SULLIVAN:
Hm, yeah. Makes sense.
I don't want to make this
like a therapy session for us.
WILL SHARPE: Okay.
I would say the root of
the tension between
Harper and Ethan,
in my opinion, and sweetheart,
you can say whatever you want.
Uh-huh.
But there's like this
underlying resentment
that is kind of building
towards Ethan for her.
ETHAN SPILLER: Why are you
threatened by them?
HARPER SPILLER: I'm not.
I was just trying to say I think
we have a good relationship,
but I won't do that again.
There's this false belief
that if you go on vacation,
-you leave your life behind.
-Leave all your problems behind.
And you actually
are just the same person,
living the same life.
And all your problems
go with you.
It doesn't matter
what the view is,
you're never gonna be happy.
Aubrey.
(CHUCKLES)
How do you guys like being rich?
Oh, Cameron. God.
Come on.
It probably effects
your sense of self
to have recently come
into a lot of money.
I don't feel like that's what
the problem is with
Ethan and Harper.
I almost feel like they are
exactly how they were
when they didn't have
as much money.
Except, they're in
a different place,
with different people.
And maybe that's the catalyst
for all the other stuff
to kind of bubble out.
I had to have
an emergency caesarean.
Daphne's guts were all over
the table, you know.
Daphne and Cameron
have this like really
tender moment about their kids.
And I think it's like the first
time Harper feels like,
"Maybe I've really
judged them harshly."
It's in those moments,
you realize just how much
you love somebody, you know?
I love you.
AUBREY: And also, maybe they
have it all figured out,
and I'm just some stuck-up bitch
that has a stick up my ass.
-Can I say that on HBO?
-Yeah.
I would pick Tanya
to go on vacation with
because she's drunk
the whole time and--
Kind of fun.
AUBREY:
She's fun, and people that have
that kind of chaotic energy,
it is soothing to me.
Because it feels like
all the drama is over there.
-I'm just watching the show.
-She seems like someone
who would kind of make friends.
'Cause she seems to be traveling
on her own quite a lot.
My go-to vacation drink
is the Aperol Spritz.
I mean, especially in Italy.
I don't think I've had one
since I got here.
-AUBREY: Really?
-No.
-What do you drink?
-I don't know.
I had some wine.
-AUBREY: Wine.
-I love carrying on.
-Yeah.
-God, there's nothing
that gets me going...
-WILLIAM: If you can.
If you can carry it all on.
...more than carrying on
a tiny little fucking suitcase,
zipping right through
the airport
and just flipping off all
the people in the baggage claim.
-Not for this trip.
-AUBREY: No.
I brought a lot of clothes
that I never wear.
For some reason.
I think I kind of panic-packed.
I'm really inconsistent
about my wake-up times.
But on vacation,
it depends on how much
I drank the night before.
Some Italian Prosecco?
No, thanks.
I have small children,
so I'm up pretty early.
You do?
-(LAUGHING)
-How am I just finding out now?
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪